Try these tips to take your act out of your living room and in front of a live audience.
Step 1: Write original material for your routine.
Whenever inspiration strikes, write it down immediately.
Step 2: Develop your act by rehearsing your material and finding an original voice.
Study successful comedians for tips on delivery, timing, and attitude.
Step 3: Get on stage often.
It's critical for a stand-up to practice before an audience as much as possible.
Step 4: Read the audience.
If you're not getting laughs, shift gears.
Be prepared to stray from your material...
...and improvise to mine comedy from spontaneous situations, and defuse hecklers.
Step 5: Record your set when you have it down, and make a DVD.
Professional comics send these to comedy clubs around the country as a way to audition for a booking.
Step 6: Show respect to fellow comedians and club owners.
Staying in good graces is crucial if you want to continue to work.
Step 7: Have one or more seasoned comics as a mentor.
Most professional comics learned a lot about the business from hanging out with older comics,...
...and listening to their words of wisdom.